Good morning John, and good morning Alice, and welcome to Earth.
It's a wonderful, terrible place and you are a member of its most wonderful and terrible species.
and you're being born into what may  be the most interesting time in human history.
If all goes well within your lifetime, humans will walk on Mars, computers will become intelligent
The paralyzed will walk again, absolute poverty will be all but eliminated, and you, Alice, may very well live
to be over 100 years of age!
Or maybe this advanced, peculiar, unique institution of human technological society
will implode, taking all humans and a good piece of the Earth with it.
It could go either way really.
In any case, both you and I will be a part of that future.
But luckily you don't really have to worry about any of that right now.
Because you are a baby.
You just have to just have to worry about being a baby.
But nobody ever said that being a baby is easy,
And so I, your Uncle Hank, have created a simply guide to how to be a baby in six easy steps.
One: You are stuck out here so get used to it.
You probably don't know this because you are a human baby,
but human babies are born pretty premature when compared to other placental mammals.
This is because our heads have evolved to be super big and their hard to get out of the mom,
after a certain point of development.
So your basically still an embryo, which is really unpleasant.
To be outside of the mother at that point,
so it's gotta suck.
You're gonna wanna be swaddled and warm.
And you're gonna want wushing noises and stuff like that.
So I suggest, that you just cry until that stuff happens.
Speaking of crying,
you will discover that making a really terrible noise is actually very easy for you.
It's basically just like making any other noise.
But you're gonna want to look like it's really difficult.
Like, squint your face up. Get it all red and puffy and cry.
Your vocal cords, right now, are designed to tap directly into your parents sympathy centers
So that's going to be a useful tool for you.
Three: I would suggest you do a lot of sleeping,
but not in, like, normal human ways.
You're gonna wanna sleep for about two and a half hours at a time.
That way your parents will approach, but never quite achieve REM sleep.
Which is going to be hilarious when they start having hallucinations.
Four: Put stuff in your mouth.
Turns out, because we are so underdeveloped as newborn babies,
your nervous system is really terrible.
So our complicated sensing is really only right around here.
So if you want to know what something is you just go *arphm*
(muffled)This is really all you need to know.
Five: Communication is the key to any effective relationship.
You really only have two ways to communicate right now.
One is the crying which we've discussed previously.
Crying is something you're gonna wanna do, just, whenever.
Pretty much all the time.
Doesn't matter really how you're feeling.
Hungry. Sleepy. Thirsty. You don't like that smell.
Your butt feels weird.
You're just bored.
Cry.
Just cry in all of those situations.
But number six, you have another communicative tool.
One you want to be more sparring with,
because it is extremely powerful.
And that,
is your cuteness.
Be careful with your cute.
It is EXTREMELY potent.
Your cute is not just about inspiring love and devotion and getting pinches on the cheeks,
and saying people saying "I, so, baby, da da!"
Your cute is the key to our hope.
Our ability to see beyond our own life span.
To feel as if we are part of a continuum that stretches back to the first self replicating life forms.
Your cute reminds us that the decisions we make now,
will someday effect you and your children and your children's children.
And that you are the next step, and hopefully a better step, in this wonderful, terrible process
that we call humanity.
I hope that's not too much pressure.
Alice, I wish that I could see you right now.
And hold you go *rasberry* all over your belly.
John, I also wish that I could see you but I won't for a little while.
But, Craig I will see you on Tuesday.